the battleground state of Wisconsin was
ordered to remove more than 200,000
people from its voter registration list
the judge say those people may have
moved but Democrats fear this will
unfairly affect votes President Trump
won the state in 2016 by fewer than 23
thousand votes overall partly because of
his surprise victory in Racine County
President Obama won the county in 2008
and 2012 and that's where we find
Adriana Diaz aged around a good morning
so water voters saying here in 2020 good
morning Democrats are calling the voter
roll purge
suppression targeting low income voters
who may move more often we spent two
days traveling across the county talking
to voters and we learned that one reason
it flips red in 2016
despite supporting Barack Obama twice is
because of low turnout here in the
left-leaning city Racine Democrats Cory
Prince with the end of lay CPS and the
renzo Santos with the Young Democrats
are getting out the vote
especially the powerful black vote
turnout among black Wisconsin Heights
fell nearly 19 percent between the 2012
and 2016 elections why David voters come
out for Hillary Clinton it was a lack of
organizing black people have realized
our vote is being taken for granted
there's a democratic America that looks
at Donald Trump as like you know he's
the worst thing ever
black people are kind of like I yawn you
know hey I've seen worse we see Donald
when we go to the bank and ask for loan
we see Donald when we get pulled over
and so Donald ain't that bad to us he's
not the worst we would love to get
behind something better give us that
picture give us the picture of something
better don't talk about what's so bad
what are the issues that you care most
about in this election if final change
is not handled it's affecting our
agriculture which is a major source of
economy in the Midwest the left-leaning
city sits on Lake Michigan but head west
and will start seeing red in the western
suburbs like here in Mount Pleasant
voters tend to be older
more conservative and more likely to
vote in 2016
City turnout was just under 52% out here
it was 70% so who's the big winner here
so far we found suburban Racine Ian's at
the Country Club playing the Chinese
game of mahjongg
most didn't want to talk politics but
lifelong Republican Mary Patterson was
gay
immigration is very important to me I
would like to see something done with
health care and also foreign policy what
do you think of the president's
decisions to have a drone strike I think
it was the right thing to do
Iran is going to back off and with this
president they know he won't hesitate
you can't tell the county story without
going further west through farmland and
small towns in Burlington it seemed like
the whole town showed up for open mic
night coming up that's where we met a
group of military wives including
Stephanie's to me I have traditionally
voted Republican but I need to just get
a better a better grasp on what the
candidates
I have to offer and what what I feel is
important to me and how I feel about it
so I you know my votes up for grabs
you're one of those voters that the
Republicans and the Democrats are
looking for hey I'm the swing vote now
but yeah I'm yeah I definitely am I'm
one of those people are you comfortable
sharing who you voted for last time
I voted for Hillary last time I might
get some I mean I don't know I just you
know I just try to vote my heart vote my
conscience what what I feel is best for
my family best for you know the country
both parties have their sights set on
these voters tonight president Trump has
this rally and nearby Milwaukee and not
to be outdone the Democrats are holding
their national convention in Milwaukee
as well Wisconsin's primary is April 7th
all right Adriana thank you very much
very interesting to hear from those
voters you know there are more than 10
million Obama voters from 2016
nationwide why they're switched to Trump
or didn't show up at all all the ones
that didn't vote overwhelmingly or
disproportionately people of color of
the ones that went to trump
overwhelmingly white a lot of them in
Wisconsin - what the bottom line is you
always have to vote yes have to vote and
what if Democrats want to win they need
to get that 10 million back on their
side they have to motivate their voters
very interesting
you